bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video sono pari j
e oggi siamo su pizza dell'eyewear i due
ragazzi hanno fatto un 2 di sta roba che
voi ci crediate o no hanno fatto un due
ragazzi hanno fatto a far uscire il 2 di
sta roba
ma sono talmente curioso di andarlo a
vedere che vi giuro non potevano giocare
quindi andiamo così questo è raggiunto
l'ultimo a casa sulla lista delle
consegne consegna la pizza voce mente
ritorna a casa ragazzi qualcosa mi dice
che a casa non ci torniamo ma io la
pizza la consegna lo stesso perché sono
un pizzaiolo modello quindi ragazzi
direi di fare il mio dovere da buon
consegnatore di pizze e cos'è cos'è una
cascata c'è una cascata questi giardino
ma chi è
bill gates cioè cos'è mio dio che
ragazzi che texture le montagne sono le
montagne più in hd che abbia mai visto
tanto si muove ragazzi se guardate
quelle si sta muovendo sembra sembra un
pene
vabbè perfetto facciamo finta di niente
mi stavo ipnotizzando non importa
entriamo in casa per permesso
sono fa vj consegna pizze un set up fece
anche l'api cos'è che cazzo di pizza è
sta roba a sono di sopra per favore
entra si metterà un minuto o chi ha
permesso che la madonna che
quadripartita stessi ed è bello
fantastico poggia la pizza sul tavo
perfetto in appoggio qui è che ti
aspetto giorno che cazzo ragazzi eve
piano licola corrente è mamma se la
sopra ragazzi e sotto effetto di droghe
e successo sarà tornerò quando lei
quando la luce sarà tornata no torna qui
lo sta dove sta andando sto facendo la
finestra ragazzi cosa sta succedendo è
praticamente non ho capito che cazzo
successo devo andare io devo riaccendere
le luci perfetto ragazzi dalla faccenda
sta diventando un frutta compresa che
cazzo era quella roba
ok ok ok buona d'orcia una torcia ora
sono peggio di magrin sulla trattativa
fuoco dove cazzo son finito dietro al
divano bene cos'è sti qua te mi fanno
venire voglia di passare le giornate a
guardarlo tutto il tuo tutto giorno dopo
ragazzi non stiamo a giudicare il quadri
andiamo di sopra anche se io lo faccio
meglio quello c'era c'era michael
jackson nello scorso fissa dei liberi
cosa mi devo aspettare adesso madonna
questo è il piano di sopra che ora le
tanto di sempre cioè chimiche sei uscito
alla finestra cioè se io fossi in lui ti
darei un semplice calcio alla finestra
me ne andrei fuori dai [ __ ] cosa che
lui non farà mai penso perfetto va bene
unico ace cellulare forse lo devo
prendere il telefono mi sto sbagliando
io c'è una borsa c'è anche un dollaro
trovati i soldi per la pizza esatto 30
amico mio
era la stessa cosa che avrei detto
anch'io lirici per sé anche la borsa nel
frattempo era un biglietto nella 50
dollari per una piccola zico e dollari
ma i restanti 45 sono di mancia e li
prendo molto volentieri grazie della
gentilezza e direi che adesso che sono
stato pagato possa uscire fuori dalle
palle perché cazzola pizza si avventa
ragazzi mamma sei qui il suo telefono
del piano di sopra sta suonando telefono
ragazzi stato nando telefono se devo
essere sincero la cosa non mi consola
per niente comunque
pizz l'ho già consegnata io i 45 dollari
di mancia mini tengono stesso inutile
che piange come uno strano pezzo di
pizza
mamma mia che frasi terrore ragazzino
non vi sentite tutti i brividi che vi
percorrono la schiena cioè fantastico e
vabbè comunque se si può uscire sono 250
finestre dio mio apri qualcosa io faccio
solo consegne non è colpa mia
amico mio vabbè io ok questa non me
l'aspettavo
senti è la pizza la pizza credo che lei
abbia mogli essere i problemi al collo
milanello non ne sono sicuro non ne sono
sicuro però sono sicuro che adesso deve
prevedere da un buon ortopedico è una
massa di yoga quella ragazzi sta
diventando tutto bullo non so che cazzo
sta succedendo di preciso ma è successo
di tutto fino adesso bene quel che
chiedo c'è sono morto non mi so non mi
sono mosso
non mi sono fottutamente mosso e è
finita è finita ragazzi è finita ce la
possiamo fare
già possiamo fare se è stato tutto un
incubo è perché hai sognato di io ho
spesso sogno di consegnare le pizze
degli horror sono ancora casa mia sto
dormendo nel mio letto non ne sono
sicuro ragazzi no non è stato sono
sempre qui ragazzi a sei sempre qui
razzo di kyoto non è stato un sogno cioè
mio dio se ce la fai a far due passi
come cazzo fai di addormentarti niente
già di quella [ __ ] che cosa sai che
cosa mi sta succedendo non lo so ma
secondo me un pezzo di quella pizzata 6
mangiata di tuo
ho bisogno di trovare la chiave per la
porta principale porca [ __ ] che genio
ma cazzo diciamo proprio pensato sai ivy
che intenzione di uscire la candela e se
e sventa c'è tanto per cambiare ho
bisogno live ok perfetto dove andare a
pieno di ragazzi devo trovare una match
box c'erano ragazzi quando sono al buio
sembra che sia strafatto tizio se
guardate che sembra sembra che sia
ubriaco a può comunque non ho capito che
cosa devo trovare ancora ma devo trovare
qualcosa che sostituisca la torcia credo
che cosa che chi ha scippato lavorano e
qui ha oscillato io la borsa cazzo è
successo dado vendiamo loro tirata fuori
dalle mutande cioè sia accesa si è
accesa la torcia raga non si sa perché
meglio così ho trovato una traccia
buongiorno ma tu sei d'ora
l'esploratrice l'autografo non vogliono
autografo subito subito deve carmelo
amica mia
ti ho cercata per così tanto tempo non
lasciare che ti insegue l'unico che
senti tuoi passi ragazzi che cazzo sta
dicendo
l'unico che ha inseguito la mia famiglia
gara stai calma possiamo uscire di qui
dove l'uscita 2 che sembrava cerca alle
cose cos'è tutto cazzo vaio che cosa
lascia le pagine dello slow and air men
per che cazzo mi ha lasciato delle
pagine a terra non te raccolgo io te ne
raccoglie i da sola
me ne frega un cazzo che sei una bambina
ma ragazzi è comunque mio addio lato la
pizza l'ho guardato a mezz'ora passi
fredda
sentito da fammi un favore fai un favore
a zio favi 20 st pizzo sui forni non ci
arriva i fornelli scusami non è che puoi
che cazzo guardi che cazzo ne è andato
da per asta bambina fonde windle chi
trova la chiave per la morto più di male
cos'è quello quello cosa che cazzo est
europa
c'era bisogno di nascondermi degli
armati nella pagina e l'armadio che
cazzo tizio è il pizzaiolo con i ragazzi
non perfetto nell'armadio velocissimo ce
l'ho fatta cosa son fatta sulla fissa
più chiudi ti chiudi la porta perfetto
ma come ha fatto la pizza a finire qui
e che ne so io c'ero
dove cazzo sia ragazzi stein botta al
personaggio se questo è sicuro che cazzo
siamo ci sono pezzi di pizza ovunque
questa è la tipo il finale ricchezza dei
libri l'uno ragazzi non vi è mai
capitato di sognare di di seguire pezzi
di pizza
io sinceramente molto spesso i ragazzi
vi giuro che ballato e meglio di michael
jackson cazzo ok ma il numero medica
fatti una pizza della consegnata in
tempo sei tu che sei messo secoli dove
cazzo siamo amici abbiamo a che cazzo e
mangiato per gli urti così la mascella
c'è un'ombra c'è un'ombra cos'è ora
possiamo giocare tutti insieme ma che
cazzo sei stato tu d'ora [ __ ] e la
pizza seppure freddata ma tanto sono
passaggi tua perché lei ordinata tu non
io comunque va bè ragazzi è stato
assurdo c'è una cosa impressionante
doloroso pensare se ci fanno un 3 di
questa roba che cazzo se fuori comunque
ragazzi concludo qui vi do perché è
stato genio non trovo parole per
descriverlo comunque 6 mille piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione assieme se non
iscritti iscrivetevi non ci vediamo al
prossimo vito bei ragazzi